the 60-foot ladder is put up against a
building the base of the ladder is eight
feet away from the building how high
will the ladder reach so let's draw this
scenario here so let's say that this is
the ground and this is the building this
is the building and then we're going to
have a 60-foot ladder and it's leaning
up against this building so the length
of this ladder is 60 feet that is a
60-foot ladder and then the base of the
ladder is eight feet away from the
building so this distance right over
here is eight is eight feet and they say
how high will the ladder reach so they
want to figure out or they want us to
figure out this height right over here
we need to figure out this height and as
we see assuming that this is a normal
building and it's built at a right angle
to the ground this triangled form by the
ladder the building in the ground is a
right triangle so the Pythagorean
theorem will apply and the Pythagorean
theorem tells us that the square or the
sum of the squares of the two shorter
sides is going to be equal to the square
of the longer side or the square of the
hypotenuse and the longest side is a
side opposite the 90-degree angle and
that's the hypotenuse so this tells us
the Pythagorean theorem tells us that 8
squared 8 squared plus h squared plus h
squared H for height is going to be
equal to 60 squared is going to be equal
to 60 squared + 8 squared is 64 64 plus
h squared is equal to 3,600 3,600
subtract 64 from both sides so let's
subtract 64 from both sides and we get h
squared H squared is going to be equal
to what is this 3536 and then this
doesn't pop out into my brain is some
type of perfect square so let's take a
calculator out so let's try it out so we
want to take the square root of
3536 second square root you see a little
square root symbol there in orange just
want to press the orange button first
square root of 3536 and i get fifty nine
point four six and they want us to round
our answer to the nearest tenth so 59
point four six six is greater than or
equal to five so round up so it rounds
up to 59 point five so H is going to be
equal to maybe I should say
approximately equal to I already forgot
the number fifty nine point five fifty
nine point five and we're done